David Boder: [In English] This is Spool number 6. A young man, Marko Moskovitz, a pupil of the ORT. The record is being taken on July 30, 1946.
David Boder: [In German] Hm, was sagen Sie ist Ihr Name?
Marko Moskovitz: Moskovitz, Marko.
David Boder: Moskovitz, Marko. Und wie lange sind Sie in Paris?
Marko Moskovitz: Zwei Wochen.
David Boder: Und wo sind Sie gekommen von Paris?
Marko Moskovitz: Von Deutschland dann nach Italien und von Italien nach Paris.
David Boder: Von Deutschland nach Italien und von Italien nach Paris.
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Und wo sind Sie geboren, Marko?
Marko Moskovitz: In den Karpaten.
David Boder: In den Karpaten.
Marko Moskovitz: Karpaten, hm, ja.
David Boder: Und wann sind Sie gekommen nach Deutschland?
Marko Moskovitz: Nach Deutschland deportiert.
David Boder: Deportiert?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: In welchem Jahr?
Marko Moskovitz: In 1942 deportiert.
David Boder: Deportiert. Wie alt sind Sie jetzt?
Marko Moskovitz: Neunzehn Jahre.
David Boder: Neunzehn Jahre. So wie alt waren Sie wenn man Sie deportiert?
Marko Moskovitz: Ich war da siebzehn Jahre.
David Boder: Sie waren siebzehn Jahre alt. Also erzählen Sie mir, wer, hm, wer waren Ihre Eltern, wer ist Ihre Familie und alles Weitere?
Marko Moskovitz: Meine..., hm, also...
David Boder: Hm?
Marko Moskovitz: Hersh war mein Vater und meine Mutter Debora und ich habe 5 Geschwister und...
David Boder: Aha.
Marko Moskovitz: Und dass wir dann deportiert sind und jetzt ich bin alleine.
David Boder: Und was war Ihres Vaters Beschäftigung?
Marko Moskovitz: Hm, ein Feldarbeiter.
David Boder: Ein Feldarbeiter. In welcher Stadt?
Marko Moskovitz: Solotvyna.
David Boder: Solotvyna. Was war das Polen?
Marko Moskovitz: Nein, das war Tschechoslowakei. Im 39’er Jahr.
David Boder: Und dann wer hat es bekommen?
Marko Moskovitz: Es war dann bei Ungarn.
David Boder: Ja.
Marko Moskovitz: Und jetzt sind dort die Russen.
David Boder: Und jetzt sind dort die Russen, aber die Ungarn haben es genommen?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Erzählen Sie mir, wie hat das passiert, wenn die Ungarn haben genommen die Tschechos..., hm, die,...ihre Stadt?
Marko Moskovitz: Hm, die waren gekommen, hm, [unverständlich] die sind herein gekommen im 39’er Jahr und...
David Boder: Ja.
Marko Moskovitz: dann hat es schon angefangen die Juden zu deportieren und—nicht zu deportieren, sondern gemacht auf Arbeit zu gehen.
David Boder: Was heißt man hat sie gemacht auf Arbeit zu gehen? Erzählen Sie mir
Marko Moskovitz: Also die gelben Bänder, wir haben angefangen zu tragen die gelben Bänder da, und mein Vater hat auch einen...
David Boder: Hat auch?
Marko Moskovitz: Mein Vater hat auch einen gelben Stern getragen.
David Boder: Und Sie?
Marko Moskovitz: Ich nicht.
David Boder: Warum nicht?
Marko Moskovitz: Ich war noch...ich war noch jung.
David Boder: Sie waren noch jung.
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Und die Frauen?
Marko Moskovitz: Die Frauen auch.
David Boder: Die Frauen auch.
Marko Moskovitz: Die Frauen sind geblieben.
David Boder: Was heißt, die Frauen sind geblieben?
Marko Moskovitz: Die Frauen haben, sind dort geblieben. Die Frauen waren im Ghetto und haben Sterne getragen.
David Boder: Aha. Wie haben sie gemacht ein Ghetto?
Marko Moskovitz: Zu Hause.
David Boder: Aber, wo...wie hat man das gemacht, Mark?
Marko Moskovitz: Man hat ausgerufen auf den Märkten, dass jeder Mensch...und dann hat man gesagt, dass alle Juden sollen in eine Gasse rein gehen.
David Boder: Ja.
Marko Moskovitz: Und da sind die rein gegangen und die Gendarmerie, die Ungarische, war dann rund um das Ghetto. Wir waren dann 4 Wochen in dem Ghetto zusammen und dann deportiert nach Auschwitz.
David Boder: Nach Auschwitz?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Warum nach Auschwitz.
Marko Moskovitz: Na so—alle Juden nach Auschwitz.
David Boder: Sind Sie auch gewesen in Auschwitz?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Alright, also erzählen Sie mir, Mark, wie hat man dort gelebt in Auschwitz? Was ist dort passiert?
Marko Moskovitz: Also man ist dort rein gekommen, mir war nicht bewusst - ich war noch jung, ich war nicht .[unverständlich]
David Boder: Warum nicht?
Marko Moskovitz: Ich war nicht ganz richtig im Kopf.
David Boder: Was heißt das?
Marko Moskovitz: Drei Tage hab ich gar nichts gewusst, nicht ob Nacht, nicht ob Tag war, ich habe nichts gewusst.
David Boder: Warum haben Sie nichts gewusst?
Marko Moskovitz: Ah so, es war also ein Rauch von dem Krematorium, ich konnte gar nichts anderes wissen.
David Boder: Wie Sie angekommen sind in Auschwitz?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja, da haben sie gesagt: „Heraustreten die Fachleute“. Da bin ich rausgetreten, denn ich war ein Tischler. Da bin ich vorgetreten und mein Vater hat gesagt: „Warum bist Du herausgetreten? Jetzt ist klar, dass mir allein und Du wirst wechseln.“ Aber es...zurücktreten hab ich auch nicht mehr können.
David Boder: Aha, und wo war Ihre Mutter?
Marko Moskovitz: Die Mutter war schon...kaputt.
David Boder: Wann?
Marko Moskovitz: An diesem Tag.
David Boder: Na, warten Sie mal. Man hat Sie genommen nach Auschwitz?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Erzählen Sie mir die ganze Geschichte.
Marko Moskovitz: Man hat die herausgenommen aus unserem Waggon. Dann hat man gesagt Frauen separat und Kinder von—bis 12, 13 und 14 Jahre sollen bleiben mit der Mutter und, hm,
David Boder: Ja.
Marko Moskovitz: . . . und die Älteren, die arbeiten können, sollen bleiben, ja, sollen bleiben auf der anderen Seite.
David Boder: Und die Mutter?
Marko Moskovitz: Und die Mutter war schon separat, denn sie hatte meine Geschwister, meinen Bruder von 10 Jahren und meine Schwester von 11 Jahren.
David Boder: Ja?
Marko Moskovitz: Und die gingen mit der Mutter. Und ich mit meinem Vater und noch einem Bruder gingen auf die andere Seite.
David Boder: Ja.
Marko Moskovitz: Und haben gesagt arbeiten nun und dann sind wir rein gekommen in einen Block und haben gesagt „Fachleute heraus treten“. Mein Vater hat geglaubt, dass ich bleiben werde in diesem Lager Auschwitz.
Marko Moskovitz: Da bin ich heraus getreten und kam gleich in einen anderen Block und dann hat man mich nach Oberschlesien transportiert, nach Breslau.
David Boder: Ja. Und wann haben Sie zuletzt gesehen Ihre Mutter?
Marko Moskovitz: Hm, wenn man uns herausgenommen hat von dem Waggon, da habe ich zum letzten Mal gesehen meine Mutter.
David Boder: Und Sie sind überzeugt, dass man...
Marko Moskovitz: Ja, was ich gesehen habe.
David Boder: Was haben Sie gesehen?
Marko Moskovitz: Man hat sie rein geschmissen.
David Boder: Wo?
Marko Moskovitz: Ins Krematorium.
David Boder: Man hat sie dort reingeschmissen—lebendig?
Marko Moskovitz: Also, man...sie haben gesagt...und man hört Schreien und dann haben sie gehört das Schreien und dann haben sie gehört das Schreien wird lauter. Und dann auf einmal werden die Türen von sie Gaskammern auf und das Schreien in der Gaskammer.
David Boder: Aha. In die Gaskammer gingen sie rein. Und dann?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja. Und die Kranken, was von [unverständlich] nicht laufen konnte, dann mit der Maschine.
David Boder: Welche Maschine?
Marko Moskovitz: Von der SS Maschinen—reingeschmissen - in die Gaskammer—ins Krematorium.
David Boder: Lebendig?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Die Kranken?
David Boder: Wie kann man das, war das Krematorium so gross, dass man Leute lebendig rein geben konnte?
Marko Moskovitz: Es war sechzig Kilometer, es war 40 Kilometer, Quadratkilometer.
David Boder: Was?
Marko Moskovitz: . . . war gross das Krematorium, wo man reingeschmissen hat.
Marko Moskovitz: Es war in einem Wald.
David Boder: Ja?
Marko Moskovitz: In einem großen Wald.
David Boder: Aber...?
Marko Moskovitz: Was war in dem Wald und da war eine große Gruft.
David Boder: Ja
Marko Moskovitz: . . . und in die Gruft hat man herein geschmissen den schwarzen Schmarren.
David Boder: Was?
Marko Moskovitz: Einen schwarzen Schmarren geschüttet , das ist was man auf die Strassen gibt, das hat man herein geschüttet.
David Boder: Ja.
Marko Moskovitz: Und das hat man angezündet und das hat gebrannt Tag und Nacht. Und die Menschen hat man rein geschmissen immer.
David Boder: Oh. Dort hat man verbrannt...verbrannt die Toten?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Verbrannt?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja, ja. Die Toten und [unverständlich] oft manche die noch leben.
David Boder: Oh, nicht in die Ofen?
Marko Moskovitz: Ach, von dem Transport diese würden in the Ofen geschmissen, diese waren, die bei der Arbeit waren, die schon Muselmann waren vom Arbeiten, diese hat man gebracht nach Auschwitz, diese - dass man die da rein schmeißt in die Gaskammern und in diese Ofen.
David Boder: Ah?
Marko Moskovitz: Also bitte, der erste Transport, der muss [unverständlich] gehen. Also da kommt ein Transport von sechzig tausend Gefangene und so ein kleiner Ofen dort und so viele Gefangene.
David Boder: Sie konnten nicht...?
Marko Moskovitz: Und da hat man sie in die Gruft rein geschmissen.
David Boder: In die Gruft?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Und was wurde in der Gruft verbrannt?
Marko Moskovitz: Menschen wurden...
David Boder: Ja, aber...
Marko Moskovitz: Holz, Holz hat man da reingelegt und auch Teer.
David Boder: Holz und Teer?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Was haben Sie vorher gesagt—ein Muselmann?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja, das ist Muselmann, der arbeitet, der arbeitet im Lager.
David Boder: Ja?
Marko Moskovitz: Und sie waren mager, nur Haut und Bein.
David Boder: Ja.
Marko Moskovitz: Und die Deutschen haben gesagt, die sind Muselmann.
David Boder: Ja?
Marko Moskovitz: Und sie werden gebracht nach Auschwitz und sie werden in die Ofen.
David Boder: Hm.
Marko Moskovitz: Aber die Transport Massen werden in die Gruft rein geschoben.
David Boder: So, das war in Auschwitz.
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Und so haben Sie...wie Sie weg sind, haben sie gesagt „die Arbeitsleute voraus“ und Sie...
Marko Moskovitz: Ja, ich bin ausgetreten.
David Boder: Was hat Ihr Vater gesagt?
Marko Moskovitz: Mein Vater hat geglaubt, ich soll bleiben in diesem Lager—in Auschwitz.
Marko Moskovitz: Aha.
David Boder: Das war Birkenau. Hier in Birkenau bin ich gekommen.
Marko Moskovitz: Nun so haben Sie Ihren Vater allein gelassen?
David Boder: Ja.
Marko Moskovitz: Und?
Marko Moskovitz: Mit dem Bruder, ein Bruder auch mit dem Vater.
David Boder: Wie alt war Ihr Bruder?
Marko Moskovitz: Dreizehn Jahre.
David Boder: Oh, so er konnte nicht arbeiten?
Marko Moskovitz: Er war gewohnt von, von zu Hause, er...er war bei der Arbeit von Mai bis August, bis, hm, Jänner.
David Boder: Hm.
Marko Moskovitz: . . . bis ins nächste Jahr. Dann wurde er transportiert von Buna nach Monowitz. Das ist in Polen, eine große Fabrik, er...
David Boder: Hat man den Bruder weggenommen von dem Vater?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja. Nein, der Bruder war mit dem Vater zusammen.
David Boder: Und der Vater war in der Fabrik?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja, mit dem Bruder, hat man sie transportiert und evakuiert. Die Russen sind da gekommen.
David Boder: Hm?
Marko Moskovitz: Und man hat sie geschickt nach Gleiwitz.
David Boder: Hm.
Marko Moskovitz: In Gleiwitz und...in Gleiwitz waren sie.
David Boder: Aha. Im ersten Lager wohin Sie gekommen sind, wo sie haben Ihre Mutter verloren, welches Lager war das?
Marko Moskovitz: Das ist Birkenau.
David Boder: Birkenau?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja, Birkenau.
David Boder: Und dort ist ihre Mutter geblieben—mit wem, mit ihrer Schwester?
Marko Moskovitz: Mit einer Schwester und einem Bruder von 8 Jahren.
David Boder: Aha. So diese sind verschwunden da?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Und dann erst Ihr Vater mit Ihrem Bruder...
Marko Moskovitz: Ja, der Vater mit dem Bruder, hm, sind weg - in einer Fabrik arbeiten.
David Boder: In einer Fabrik?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: In welcher Fabrik haben sie gearbeitet?
Marko Moskovitz: In Buna.
David Boder: In Buna.
David Boder: Und wie lange waren sie dort?
Marko Moskovitz: Sie waren von Mai...
David Boder: Ja. Bis?
Marko Moskovitz: . . . bis Jänner. Im Jänner hat man begonnen mit Evakuieren.
David Boder: Aha?
Marko Moskovitz: Sie sind gegangen bis Gleiwitz Eins. In Gleiwitz Eins—in Gleiwitz Eins und mehr—dann weiß ich nicht.
David Boder: Aha. Woher wissen Sie, wo sie waren? Haben sie geschrieben?
Marko Moskovitz: Ich habe einen Cousin.
David Boder: Hm.
Marko Moskovitz: Der war mit ihnen zusammen.
David Boder: Oh, einen Cousin haben Sie, der war mit Ihnen zusammen?
Marko Moskovitz: Nein, er war mit meinem Vater zusammen.
David Boder: Mit ihrem Vater?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Und er hat Ihnen das gesagt?
David Boder: Ja. Und wo haben Sie gearbeitet?
Marko Moskovitz: Ich hab gearbeitet in Oberschlesien.
David Boder: In Oberschlesien. Ja. In was für einer Fabrik haben Sie gearbeitet?
Marko Moskovitz: Das war eine Station.
David Boder: Was?
Marko Moskovitz: Das war eine Station. Das hat eine, hm, ja, wir haben gemacht eine Station.
David Boder: Eine, eine Eisenbahn -...
Marko Moskovitz: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Station.
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Sie haben gebaut?
David Boder: Sie sind ein Tischler?
Marko Moskovitz: Nein. Da ist das egal. Ein Tischler, hm, die Goldarbeiter ist egal, sie alle tragen Zement—und, hm, [unverständlich].
David Boder: Nun und, hm, wie hat man Sie behandelt dort im Lager?
Marko Moskovitz: Sie geben für acht Mann ein Brot.
David Boder: Ja?
Marko Moskovitz: Das Brot war ein Kilo vierzig.
David Boder: Ja.
Marko Moskovitz: Und wir kriegen einen schwarzen Kaffee. Und für mittags dann eine klare Suppe und abends dann eine klare Suppe und dann [unverständlich].
David Boder: Aha. Und nun wenn jemand war krank?
Marko Moskovitz: Na, dann hilft nicht. Wenn jemand ist krank, dann muss es von selbst gut werden. Wenn nicht, dann geht er nach Auschwitz.
David Boder: Und hat das passiert?
Marko Moskovitz: Hm, das passiert von unserem Lager in drei Viertel, es bleibt ein Viertel.
David Boder: Und man hat die Anderen genommen—nach was? Nach Auschwitz?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja, hat man—nach Auschwitz - hat jeder verbrennt.
David Boder: Und wo haben Sie gearbeitet dort?
Marko Moskovitz: Ich arbeit Dies, Jenes.
David Boder: Im Januar.
Marko Moskovitz: Im Januar, ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Marko Moskovitz: Im Januar hatten sie uns evakuiert bis Prag.
David Boder: Ja?
Marko Moskovitz: Und von Prag nach Groß-Rosen - alles per Fuß. Und dann hat man uns reinwagoniert in die Wagon, 120 Mann nach Flossenbürg. In Flossenbürg war, waren wir 2 Monate, dann hat man uns nach Offenburg. Von Offenburg hat man uns eingeladen in die Wagon, weil die Amerikaner sind gekommen. Hat man unterwegs, hat man den, hat man geschossen und nur einige wenige Leute sind geblieben am Leben. Und dann sind wir aus dem großen Wagon gerannt in den großen Wald, in den Schwarzwald und dort waren auch freie andere Franzosen.
David Boder: Franzosen?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Nun und dann wohin sind sie gegangen von dort??
Marko Moskovitz: Von dort konnte ich, hm, gehen, aber ich war sehr schwach. zweiunddreißig (32) Kilo hab ich nur gehabt. Aber ich konnte gehen, aber nicht sehr weit gehen.
David Boder: Sie haben sich selbst gewogen.
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Mit zweiunddreißig (32) Kilo?
David Boder: Wie hoch sind Sie?
Marko Moskovitz: Ich bin einen Meter siebzig.
David Boder: Sie sind einen Meter siebzig?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Und Sie haben gewogen zweiunddreißig (32) Kilo
David Boder: Nun?
Marko Moskovitz: Und ich war drei Monate...
David Boder: Wo?
Marko Moskovitz: Dort in dem...Immendingen hat es geheißen, das Dorf da in Bayern, ja.
David Boder: Ja?
Marko Moskovitz: Und dann...
David Boder: Wer hat sie ernährt dort?
Marko Moskovitz: Wir waren es. Und dann...
David Boder: Was heißt das? Wer war mit Ihnen da?
Marko Moskovitz: Andere, Russen waren, Soldaten von verschiedene Firmen.
David Boder: Und wie haben Sie sich ernährt?
Marko Moskovitz: Also, wir sind rein, die Deutschen waren alle weg. Wein haben wir in der Stube gefunden und Essen.
David Boder: Ah, die Deutschen waren weg?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Ja und nun?
Marko Moskovitz: Dann sind wir gefahren nach Regensburg, nach Regensburg. Von Regensburg nach München war ich schon bis zur letzten Zeit. Dann bin ich nach Italien.
David Boder: Wie sind Sie gegangen von München nach Italien? Hat man Ihnen erlaubt zu gehen?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja. Wir sind mit dem Transport nach Italien.
David Boder: Wer hat es erlaubt?
Marko Moskovitz: Die Amerikaner haben es erlaubt.
David Boder: Und sie gingen wohin? Nach Italien?
Marko Moskovitz: Nach Italien, ja.
David Boder: Was, Sie haben Ihnen erlaubt zu gehen nach Italien?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Was haben Sie gedacht, warum nach Italien?
Marko Moskovitz: Weil man hat mir erzählt, dass niemand mehr zu Hause sei und warum dann nach Hause. So bin ich nach Italien.
David Boder: Oh, ansonsten wären Sie gegangen nach Hause?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Aha.
Marko Moskovitz: Weil niemand zu Haus.
David Boder: Wie sind Sie gekommen nach Italien? Haben Sie genommen einen Zug?
Marko Moskovitz: Wir bekommen einen Transport, ganze Transport.
David Boder: Waren da viele,...viele Juden, ja?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja, wir waren zweihundert (200).
David Boder: Und wo sind die Anderen hin gegangen?
Marko Moskovitz: Die Anderen sind gegangen, sie haben gefunden Arbeit und blieben in Italien, manche kommen nach Frankreich. Viele haben..., in Amerika haben sie Freund...
David Boder: Aha.
Marko Moskovitz: . . . und sie bekommen Affidavit und sind nach dort gekommen, ja.
David Boder: Sagen Sie mal, wo waren Sie in Italien?
Marko Moskovitz: In Torino.
David Boder: In Torino und, hm, wen..., wer..., wo haben Sie gegessen
Marko Moskovitz: Im UNRRA Camp.
David Boder: Die UNRRA.
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: [unverständlich] zu leben?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja, zu essen und zu schlafen.
David Boder: Ah, hm. Und denn? Warum sind sie gekommen nach Frankreich?
Marko Moskovitz: Weil ich war noch jung, ich wollte lernen ein Fach.
David Boder: Aha. Und in Italien geht das nicht?
Marko Moskovitz: Nein, in Italien gibt’s keine Fach [unverständlich].
David Boder: Aha. Und wer hat Ihnen gesagt, dass Sie gehen sollen nach Frankreich?
Marko Moskovitz: Andere Leute sind gegangen, so bin ich auch gegangen...
David Boder: Wie sind Sie gegangen nach Frankreich—per Eisenbahn?
Marko Moskovitz: Nein
David Boder: Wie denn?
Marko Moskovitz: Über Alpen.
David Boder: Sie sind über die Alpen gegangen?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Warum?
Marko Moskovitz: Warum? Ich muss so kommen, weil ich habe kein Geld für gehen mit dem Zug, war zu viel Geld...[unverständlich]
David Boder: Sind zu Fuß über die Alpen gegangen?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Wie lange hat das gedauert?
Marko Moskovitz: Zwei Tage und eine Nacht.
David Boder: So—zu gehen über die Alpen?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Haben die Franzosen Sie reingelassen?
Marko Moskovitz: Wir waren da rein gekommen im französischen Dorf haben wir gegessen und geschlafen. Dann haben wir gebeten bei einem Komitee um Geld und sind dann gekommen nach Paris.
David Boder: Haben Sie ein Einreise-Visum bekommen?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Und wer hat Ihnen das gegeben?
Marko Moskovitz: Wir sind so rein gekommen.
David Boder: Was?
Marko Moskovitz: Kein Einreise-Visum.
David Boder: [lacht etwas] Sie haben kein Visum gehabt! Wie haben die Franzosen Sie herein gelassen?
Marko Moskovitz: Gut. Wir haben gesagt, wir sind Deportierte und wir haben kein...niemand zu Hause, wo sollen wir da hin? Wir wollen zum Arbeiten nach Paris, zum Fach lernen.
David Boder: Aha.
Marko Moskovitz: Fach lernen.
David Boder: Alright, so sind sie gekommen nach Paris.
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Und wie haben Sie gefunden die Menschen?
Marko Moskovitz: Also gefunden habe ich einen Mensch, ein Jud, er war im Zug von mir und ist auch gekommen. Ich hab ihn gefragt, wo ich kann bleiben in Paris und er hat gesagt: „Ich nehm Dich heim für zwei, drei Tag’.
David Boder: Hier?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja, Paris.
David Boder: Und?
Marko Moskovitz: Und ich war dort zwei oder drei Tage. Dann bin ich weg nach (Venesse a gis?) und von dort hat man geschickt nach Pert (?).
David Boder: Nach wo?
Marko Moskovitz: Pert.
David Boder: Wo ist das?
Marko Moskovitz: Nahe bei Paris.
David Boder: Aha! Nun und denn?
Marko Moskovitz: Und da hat man mir gegeben zu essen und zu schlafen. Und ich habe gesagt, dass ich ein Fach lernen will.
David Boder: Aha. Und wo haben Sie gefunden Ihren Cousin?
Marko Moskovitz: Mit meinem Cousin komme ich zusammen von Italien.
David Boder: Aber wo haben Sie ihn gefunden?
Marko Moskovitz: Wir waren noch in Deutschland zusammen, nach der Befreiung habe ich ihn gefunden.
David Boder: Oh, nach der Befreiung?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Und erzählen Sie mir, wie haben Sie sich gefunden? Bitte.
Marko Moskovitz: Ich bin gekommen nach Regensburg.
David Boder: Ja.
Marko Moskovitz: Man hat mir gesagt, er ist in München. Und ich komme nach München und habe ihn gefunden in der Kaserne.
David Boder: In der Kaserne.
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Und war er von Ihrer Stadt?
David Boder: War er zusammen mit Ihnen?
Marko Moskovitz: Nein, mit meinem Vater.
David Boder: Wieso, hm, war...war er mit Ihrem Vater? Wieso?
Marko Moskovitz: Wieso?
David Boder: Ist er der junge Mann, der war mit Ihnen?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Ja?
Marko Moskovitz: Er war mit dem Vater zusammen. Und sein Vater war mit mir zusammen in Flossenbürg.
David Boder: Ihr Vater war mit ihm zusammen?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja, und mein...
David Boder: Und sein Vater war mit Ihnen in Flossenbürg.
Marko Moskovitz: Ja, In Flossenbürg.
David Boder: Aha. Nun, haben sie Verwandte hier in Paris?
Marko Moskovitz: Nein.
David Boder: Sie haben keine.
Marko Moskovitz: In Amerika habe ich, aber ich weiß keine Adresse.
David Boder: In welcher Stadt?
Marko Moskovitz: Das weiß ich nicht. Ich weiß den Namen von, hm, den Namen.
David Boder: Haben Sie gesprochen mit HIAS?
Marko Moskovitz: Was ist das? Mit wem?
David Boder: Das ist die amerikanische Vermittlung in Paris. Haben Sie damit gesprochen?
Marko Moskovitz: Nein, nein, noch nicht.
David Boder: Warum suchen Sie die nicht auf und reden mit denen?
Marko Moskovitz: Weil ich weiß vor dem Krieg haben wir gekriegt jede zwei Wochen—haben wir gekriegt Post. Aber wie wir nach Auschwitz deportiert sind alle, haben sie verbrennt alle Dokumente und ich weiß die Adresse nicht.
David Boder: Ja, aber...
Marko Moskovitz: Ich war da noch zu jung und habe mir nichts gemerkt. Ich weiß nicht.
David Boder: Ja, aber wissen Sie nicht in welcher Stadt er lebt?
Marko Moskovitz: Nein.
David Boder: Wissen Sie, dass es dieses Komitee, ein amerikanisches Komitee, gibt hier das sucht Verwandte?
Marko Moskovitz: Wo? Hier in Paris?
David Boder: Hier in Paris, yes, ein sehr feines Komitee.
Marko Moskovitz: Ich weiß die Adresse nicht.
David Boder: Man nennt es die HIAS.
Marko Moskovitz: Die HIAS?
David Boder: Ja.
Marko Moskovitz: Und wie lange kann das dauern? Wie lange...
David Boder: Dauern...drei Monate, es kann dauern sechs Monate, aber den finden sie gewöhnlich. Hm, hm, dieses Komitee ist hier in Paris. Sie fragen Herrn Bramson. Er wird sich mit denen in Verbindung setzen; und sie geben ihm den Namen und sie...
Marko Moskovitz: Den Namen des Onkels?
David Boder: . . . geben das in die News—in die Zeitungen und dann wird schon.
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: . . . dann wird schon jemand gefunden. Verstehen Sie?
David Boder: Und sonst—wo denken Sie zu bleiben? Wohin wollen Sie gehen, wenn Sie haben gelernt ein Fach?
Marko Moskovitz: Vielleicht wenn man findet meinen Onkel in Amerika, vielleicht werd ich dort gehen.
David Boder: Und sonst?
Marko Moskovitz: Und sonst—hab nirgendwo hin zu gehen. Muss bleiben in Paris.
David Boder: Alright. Ich habe hier ein paar Bilder und ich will, dass Sie mir sagen, was ihre Meinung von die Bilder ist. Zum Beispiel: was ist das?
Marko Moskovitz: Das ist ein Bild.
David Boder: Ja, aber beschreiben Sie. Was ist es? Was denken Sie ist es?
Marko Moskovitz: Das ist eine Frau.
David Boder: Ja, hm?
Marko Moskovitz: Eine Arbeitsfrau.
David Boder: Ja.
Marko Moskovitz: Und ist sehr verklärt.
David Boder: Ist verklärt?
Marko Moskovitz: Ja.
David Boder: Was denken Sie, denkt sie?
Marko Moskovitz: Sie denkt an ihren Mann und an ihre Kinder.
David Boder: Hm, alright, was ist das?
Marko Moskovitz: Das war im Lager.
David Boder: Ja?
Marko Moskovitz: Ein Bruder zum Anderen hat gesagt: ‚Ah, ich bin jetzt krank, aber vielleicht wirst du nach Hause gehen, um zu sagen dem Vater, ich muss sterben.’ Also passiert in einem Lager.
David Boder: Was ist das? Moment, bitte—was ist dies?
Marko Moskovitz: Das ist zwei Mal Damen.
David Boder: Ja. Erzählen Sie mir, was kommt da vor?
Marko Moskovitz: Die sehen aus wie zwei Schwestern.
David Boder: Ja. Was hat passiert?
Marko Moskovitz: Sie haben vielleicht nach dem Krieg...Einem mit dem Anderen (zu leise—murmelt—unverständlich)
David Boder: Sprechen Sie lauter! Ja. Und was ist das?
Marko Moskovitz: Das ist ein Mensch.
David Boder: Ja. Und was?
Marko Moskovitz: Er sieht aus wie ein Muselmann.
David Boder: Ja? Sprechen Sie lauter. Wie sieht er aus?
Marko Moskovitz: Wie ein Muselmann.
David Boder: Ja? Was ist ein Muselmann?
Marko Moskovitz: Ein Muselmann ist ein Mensch Haut und Bein.
David Boder: Wer hat ihn genannt den Muselmann?
Marko Moskovitz: Was?
David Boder: Wer hat sie genannt Muselmann?
Marko Moskovitz: Die Deutschen.
David Boder: Und was haben sie getan mit dem Muselmann?
Marko Moskovitz: Sie haben gesagt: ‚Du bist ein Muselmann, du hast kein Recht zum Leben.’
David Boder: Und dann?
Marko Moskovitz: Und danach reden: „Steh auf, Mensch, Du darfst nicht leben. Geh nach Krematorium.’
David Boder: Ah hm. Und was ist das?
Marko Moskovitz: Und das ist zwei Frauen und ein Mann—arbeiten—im Feld arbeiten.
David Boder: Ja?
Marko Moskovitz: Und das - vielleicht sind sie in Amerika.
David Boder: Hm. Alright. Und was ist das?
Marko Moskovitz: Das ist ein Kind. Was der Doktor dem gelernt hat ist eine Fiedel. Und er kann es spielen, weil er gut war.
David Boder: Was war er?
Marko Moskovitz: Weil er gut war, kann er es spielen.
David Boder: Aha, nun?
David Boder: [In English] This concludes the interview with Mark Moskovski on July 30, 1946, a boy of, hm, Czechoslovakia, age 19.